bonjour un adage alors ça y est le
cortège est parti c'est
[Musique]
l'errance pour elle un coup de barre à 2
fidèle à une somme de plusieurs sont
pleines de gilet jaune étonné de la voir
vous l'entendez pas être derrière moi un
des slogans hostiles à emmanuel matheron
et à son gouvernement prenait lé symbole
en fait l'obligation vaccinale pour cet
honneur professionnel rien ils
protestent également contre le bacille
vaccinale 1 récemment les taire
définitivement adopté par le parlement
et qui donc mise en oeuvre enfin s'il
proteste également contre la hausse des
tarifs de allait les céder
certaines matières premières et du
carburant nous avec jérôme intrigue est
en une des figures de ce mouvement à
leur chef a été blessée qui a perdu son
oeil il y avait pas un jour pour jour
est la place de la bastille jérôme vous
êtes toujours sur le terrain trois ans
après avoir été blessé après avoir perdu
un oeil alors cette manifestation elle a
débuté place de la bastille tout à
l'heure c'est en quoi même en que vous
avez été blessée qu'est ce que ça qu'on
fait trois ans après les faits les bons
choix et ça change pas grand chose parce
que je vois toujours rien de mon oeil
c'est surtout pour mettre l'accent
qu'aujourd'hui il ya toujours pas de
justice ça fait trois ans malgré les
vidéos malgré l'épreuve malgré le fait
que même le policier s'est dénoncé qu'il
n'y a toujours pas eu de justice au même
titre que l'ensemble de mes collègues
qui ont été blessés mutilés bon voilà
c'est surtout ça à moi ce qui me gêne
aujourd'hui c'est de pas pouvoir obtenir
réparation dont psychologiquement c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué pour toute la
famille c'est compliqué pour l'ensemble
des mutilés aujourd'hui qui aussi
attendent justice
vous manifestez samedi après samedi
[Musique]
3 à 3 pourquoi il y aurait intérêt à
faire silence aujourd'hui il serait
difficile de devoir faire silence sur la
contestation à quoi ça sert de peut-être
réveiller les consciences je le vois au
niveau de ma page mon regret c'est
officiel le nombre d'abonnés qui
aujourd'hui nous rejoignent et je vous
garantis que ce ne sont pas des filets
jaunes aujourd'hui je le répète il ya un
mécontentement qui s'installe en france
beaucoup de gens tombent sur le marché
de la précarité qui n'est pas du coq au
vide dû aussi à la hausse des prix et de
tout ce que peuvent subir les français
au delà des lois liberticides
aujourd'hui tu as une majorité de deux
français dont 7 millions de français qui
ont tenu bon face à toutes les
saloperies qu'on a pu le remettre dans
la tronche les insultes enfin si tu veux
si aujourd'hui fera disparaître de la
rue il n'en tient qu'à macron parce que
c'est lui qui est générateur aujourd'hui
ce mécontentement à chaque fois qu'il
prend la parole c'est pour te donner un
ordre d'idée je prends 20 mille abonnés
sur ma page tu vois donc si à un moment
donné c'est lui le problème alors sur le
premier mis leurs règles en ayant un peu
plus de respect vis-à-vis de sa
population vis-à-vis de son peuple soit
disant l'a élu légitimement choix un
moment donné la contestation continuera
on est vraiment la seule force
d'opposition aujourd'hui de
mécontentement quand tu vois ce qui se
passe dans l'assemblée où tout le monde
vote le doigt levé sur la couture pour
ne serait-ce que accomplir la la la le
sombre dessein de notre président on est
obligé d'être dans la rue aujourd'hui on
est obligé mais vous perdez pas
suffisamment serein si on ne laisse pas
quoi parce qu'aujourd'hui on va le
calcul est au nombre de forces en
présence dans la rue j'aime voir les
messages que je reçois d'accord le
nombre de mécontentement quand on
m'attend dans la rue le bâtard sinon
allez journée une loi qui sont vote
allait y apparaît à cinq ans parce que
les gens ne viennent pas dans la rue si
tu veux encore moi je me balade dans la
rue à des gens qui me disent mais moi je
vais pas venir à avoir un oeil crevé
j'ai besoin de nourrir mes enfants j'ai
besoin de garder mon travail d'accord
j'ai pas envie d'être arrêté par la
police j'ai pas envie de me faire blessé
par la police est ce que tu crois
qu'aujourd'hui en france et des
conditions correctes pour pouvoir
manifester et exprimer le bon c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une inertie en
france les choses sont pas capables de
réaliser quelque chose qui va pas
cesser quand on se sent concerné par les
problèmes qu'on finit par réagir mais
est-ce que réagir à mon modèle ça va pas
être trop tard aussi tu vois une
élection présidentielle qui va avoir
lieu dans trois mois pourquoi est-ce que
vous n'allez pas chercher à peser sur ce
scrutin parce qu'elle est posée
parce que tu as aujourd'hui des médias
mainstream qui monopolise le temps de
parole a donné la parole à des gens bien
installé en politique et qui vont pas
donner la parole à des citoyens qui
aujourd'hui proposent un programme
présidentiel au même titre que ton corps
tu citoyenne 2022 qui a mis en progrès
en place un programme avec 20 thèmes
représentés par fabrice grimal ou un
travail de fond a été fait pendant trois
ans et je ne parle que d'un cas parce
que ceux qui répondent tous les travaux
qui ont été effectués sur les quais les
jeunes ne serait ce que pour la
reconnaissance totale du vote blanc ya
énormément de travail de fond qui ont
été faits mais dans les règles dans les
médias meanstream on est pris pour des
salopards les destructeurs des gens qui
veulent faire les poches des français
alors que pas du tout on a des
propositions parce que on est confronté
aujourd'hui à la vie de tous les jours
moi j'étais dans le périgord où tu as
des vendeurs de foie gras qu'ils sont
capables de faire rayonner la france
dans le monde entier et à des mecs au
gouvernement qui vont te donner de
leçons qui sont pas capables de vendre
des sous-marins
c'est votre cas
il ya des candidatures gilet jaune qui
sont proposés des candidatures du groupe
de travail qui ont été mis en place mais
tu n'entendras pas parler dans les
médias mainstream
et j'ai difficile vous êtes sur le
terrain vous êtes présents n'auront
aucune crédibilité besoin des médias
mais au moins tu veux vous faire un pas
mais parce que c'est aujourd'hui la
force de frappe de propagande du
gouvernement
quand tu as des gens qui bloquent devant
leur télé si tu veux il n'ya pas une
autre approche aujourd'hui de
l'information qui permettrait aux gens
d'avoir conscience de ce qui se passe si
tu veux pas ce qu'on va leur dire
carrément internet à ces finales parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans le microcosme
d'internet les algorithmes vont nous
enfermer dans une bulle qui va être
difficile de faire de transpercer pour
pouvoir aller au delà et d'intéresser
les gens moi je le vois dans la rue la
dèche quand moi je me balade dans la rue
les gens j'arrive à les convaincre alors
expliquer les choses tu vois aujourd'hui
si tu veux rien si on reprend le
problème des augmentations de taxes bon
en suivant sur un billet de 100 euros
d'essence on va donner 60 euros de taxes
d'accord c'est cher tout le monde l'a
compris les gens sont à la gorge on n'en
peut plus mais la vraie question gilet
jaune c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
60 euros aujourd'hui pour qu'il y ait
encore des gens qui dorment dans la rue
pour qu'on puisse ne pas avoir de place
à l'hôpital pour que quand on va devant
un service public on doit faire la queue
qu'on doit galéré des mois avant de
récupérer un papier on nous prend 60
euros mais on a toujours au moins
accepter temps de justifier aujourd'hui
ses 60 euros et c'est ça c'est pas de
mécontentement et quand je discute avec
des grands patrons
je suis pas l'anti ville anticapitaliste
battu pour un capitalisme raisonner mais
quand tu discutes avec les grands
patrons qui te disent que leurs charges
patronales elle sert à quoi elle sert à
financer le système pour carrefour et à
licencier 1500 personnes dont il serait
grand temps aujourd'hui que l'ensemble
de la population française que tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui met de l'argent sur la
table pour faire vivre la france
demandent des comptes où va l'argent
parce que là ya peut-être des
analphabètes comme il a été dit à la
télé et ça c'est des gens qui savent
compter parce qu ils s'affrontaient
l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas alors que les
autres gèrent notre pays avec des
milliards et font n'importe quoi donc on
se retrouve dans la merde on nous a pris
60 euros soit 100 euros d'essence et on
nous a supprimé 17 min qu'est ce qu'on a
fait de cet argent
un espoir aujourd'hui eric emmanuel
lacroix laisse sa place à quelqu'un
d'autre est ce que vous avez un espoir
que l'élection présidentielle sa charge
quelqu'un cherche nadège aujourd'hui
dans monsieur
milliardaire détenteur d'une marque de
voiture électrique qui se paye le luxe
d'aller dans l'espace
et tu crois que lui va se plier au
gouvernement ils sont tous là avec des
bonnes propositions pour améliorer ce
qu'on appelle le pouvoir d'achat moi
j'appelle ça le mieux vivre pour un
rachat sa concept de marketing tout en
offrant à total des niches fiscales qui
vont leur permettre de moins payer
d'impôts par an un boulanger donc ils ne
font rien ils n'ont pas la face s'ils
n'ont pas le poids des lobbys
aujourd'hui tout simplement avec un peu
de chance ils sont mêmes actionnaires
tellement ils ont le pognon qu'on leur a
donné grâce à leurs pairs grâce à notre
argent ils vont pas aller à l'encontre
de l'or ceux qui les financent aussi
car moment donné session revoit la
totalité des choses on renverse à table
et on redonne le pouvoir aux citoyens et
on fait payer ceux qui doivent de
l'argent aujourd'hui à la france et pas
que ceux qui vivent et les choisir ont
beaucoup mieux mais ils n'ont pas de
force ils n'ont pas de poids il peut
faire tous les blablas qui veulent à la
télé et des promesses n'engagent que
ceux qu'il est qui qui qui qui en parle
aujourd'hui le constat est le suivant on
ne demande pas la population française
qu'est ce qu'on attend tous les sens
combien leur demander un non et après on
doit se taire et ça les français ne le
vole plus aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup donc vous l'avez entendu
jérôme rodriguez qui est des eaux
polaires rencontre le gouvernement pas
seulement c'est tout un système
politique un qu'il faut supprimer selon
lui la même manifestation se poursuit on
est toujours boulevard de l'hôpital et
puis jérôme rodriguez qui n'attend pas
grand-chose en ont plus de l'élection
présidentielle à venir tout comme
famille lellouche août à leur
mercie ans nadège pour toutes ces
précisions et plus